- We are gonna try to,
like, sneak some messages in
about women's right,
you love women.
- I love women, I love rights,
I, mixing them up, we'll
see what happens today.
- Let's get started.
- Okay, Jake, go
ahead and walk in,
Miss Benz, I'm Dr. Dong.
- Miss Benz, I'm Dr. Dong.
- Dong?
Is that French?
- Is that French?
- No, it's Korean.
- [Glasses Guy] I was adopted.
- I was adopted,
and raised in Seoul.
- I do a monthly exam--
- On my titties.
- [Nikki] But I
could use some help.
- But I could use some help.
- [Glasses Guy] Miss
Benz, this is a hospital.
- Miss Benz, this is a hospital.
- We don't call
them titties here.
We don't call them titties
here, they are ba-zoingas.
- [Nikki] What's this?
- What's this?
- [Glasses Guy] That's a uh--
- [Doctor] That's a uh--
- Titty listener.
- [Doctor] Titty listener.
- What are they saying?
- Hold on, let me
translate from the Korean.
Believe it or not, they're
saying "ah-ooh-ga!"
(laughing)
- Push her down like you're
gonna start eating her pussy.
Just another day at the office.
- This is the best meal you'll
ever have at this hospital.
- Actually, you're wrong.
We do a really good
Salisbury steak here.
(moaning)
- I want you to leave me messier
than your handwriting
on a prescription.
- I want you to leave me messier
than your handwriting
on a prescription.
- That's a classic doctor joke.
(moaning)
- This is a blow job.
♪ Blow jobs, blow jobs
♪ It's the funnest thing to do
♪ If I had my wish I would
♪ Give a blow job
♪ Every single day
♪ Well it's your lucky day
♪ Because I happen to be a genie
♪ Imma grant your wish
of allowing you to
♪ Daily suck my peeny ♪
- Yes!
- It's a whole new world!
- I feel like Aladdin.
- And I'm not Jafar
from blowing my load.
(laughing)
- Yes.
- I'm gonna finish
inside of you.
- But on the off chance
that I get pregnant--
- Do you perform abortions here?
- [Glasses Guy] Yes, but--
- Yes, but--
- Since you're a woman,
I have to counsel
you against it--
- Then you're gonna
have to wait 24 hours--
- I'm gonna call a pastor--
- He'll get in touch--
- Tell you why you're
wrong for doing it--
- And then if you really, really
decide you're gonna do it--
- I will tell everybody
where you live.
- I will tell everyone
- Okay--
- Maybe just come
on my tits then?
- Okay, so turn around
and accept his deposit.
- I consent, I consent!
- Nothing's sexier than
enthusiastic consent.
- Oh, I'm about to
shatter the glass ceiling
with my load.
And do it, shatter that ceiling.
(groaning)
I've never told a
man to come before.
(laughing)
Or have I?